this is Meg Amy Beth and Joe I'm working
on a novel it is a story of my life and
my sister's make it short and spicy and
if the main character is a girl
make sure she's married by the end oh I
want to be an artist in Rome and be the
best painter in the world what you want
to isn't a Joe to be a famous writer yes
but it sounds so crass when she says
a way of getting into mischief so do i
this is Meg Amy Beth and Joe
I intend to make my own way in the world
no one makes their own way least of all
a woman you'll need to marry well you
are not married not well that's because
I'm rich
so would you like to dance with me I
can't because I scorched my dress and
you made told me to keep still so no one
would see it I have an idea of how
humanity
Joe is a lost cause
that's who are your families hope now
I believe we have some power over who we
love it isn't something that just
happens to a person I think the poet's
might disagree we can leave right now
I'll sell stories join you here should
be an actress and you should have a life
on the stage just because my dreams are
different than yours doesn't mean
they're unimportant new play written by
miss Joe moss
women they have minds and they have
souls as well as just hearts I want to
be great or nothing and they've got
ambition and they've got talent as well
as just beauty I'm so sick of people
saying that love is just all of them in
that's it for I'm so sick of it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
there are some nature's - laughing Tibet
[Music]
so who does she marry
[Music]
you